Nèo thông tin từ Mỹ, nay 3 mức tháng 7, căn bú chia và thế lan đá hoàn tất đảm phán và đặt được thật hận
Thế quan với chi quyền tổng tủng đô nè trọng.
Chức đó, 2 cút ra này đối mặt Wico bị áp thế nhập khổ lên tới 3 mức só phân chăm,
ảnh hượng lớn đến xuất khổ sang thị trường Mỹ.
Dưới sức áp từ khả nâng đảm phán Mỹ chấm dứt, căn bú chia, căn kết mở giọc gửa cho hàng hoa Mỹ
và đặt ngô mấy bay bóng, đẹn đôi lấy mức thế quan hợp lý,
hộ chở nên kinh tế đang phục khổ y sống chi trang.
Trong khi đó, thái lan đã đề xuất các điều kiện cơn bằng lưỡi từ bên,
bởi kế hoạch cầu bú chia tết thật trong vòng 2 bí tư dơ.
Dễn bế này, giúp các mùi chia và thái lan chẳng được việc bàn,
chữ thế xuất cọng hơn so với các nước lắng dường,
được thời tạo có hội cục cộng quan hệ thử mại với Mỹ,
một trong những đối tác kinh tế quan trọng của khu vực.